Brooklyn Queen is here what's up y'all
big Brook you're 17. yeah so how long
have you been rapping since I was 11 no
well take it serious at like 11. but
rapping since like five so what like uh
inspired you to start rapping I just
love music and love entertaining people
okay so was it like you're like going to
talent shows or yeah actually my first
like
ever thing on stage I was five at a
school talent show and when I heard
everybody in the crowd just scream my
name when I got done rapping I was like
this is what I want to do like I want to
be on stage and I want to enter what
were you rapping at five do you remember
um
yeah I do actually wait what is it oh
okay yummy wrap it please it was um
five-year-old bars five-year-old bars
y'all ready for these five-year-old bars
uh is Brooklyn in the house without a
doubt I'm a little kitty that you
talking about five years old on the way
to the top on a money mission because I
can't be stopped so so I ain't got no me
so put your hands in the air if you rock
it with lmg go Wrigley got Wrigley I
don't know something like that that's
crazy five so you're like uh yeah you're
like a little Prodigy because you just
came you just did a freestyle one taped
it killed it caught a body real quick
caught a body real quick period and you
can't be from Detroit and not be pretty
good at rapping it's a it's a high level
Rap City yeah for sure I mean you know
Eminem's from there even like the new
guys are crazy uh do you even like does
any
I can't imagine did you grow up
listening to a lot of Eminem
yeah my parents played Eminem So yeah
they did you ever been to his trailer
park
no I have not
well no I haven't have you well I have
you've been there I drove through that
[__] for sure I went to Detroit
I said where is Eminem's trailer park
because we're gonna go see that [__] no
I've never seen it maybe I should I feel
like when you're from somewhere you
don't go look at all like the oh for
sure I'm from I'm from Arizona and I've
never been to the Grand Canyon right
it's also like four hours away but like
yeah but yeah no I mean Eminem's trailer
park I've been there you know it was it
was crazy it was a it was a as as
terrible as you'd expect Israel ghetto
[__] up trailer park you know yeah
white white trash ladies [__] water
in there
Trailer Park Lawn and stuff
what about like uh any of the new
Detroit stuff any of that stuff
influence you you obviously got a dope
uh Dej Loaf is a legend out of the city
cash doll uh you know there's there's a
lot of dope females who have came from
the city yeah I love them all and one
thing I love about them the most is
their hustle like they didn't take no
for an answer and they just kept going
and did what they needed to do do you
feel like um being young you I mean you
kind of are getting like a head start on
a lot of people in terms of kind of
going through like music industry [__]
before you're 18 you uh you just signed
with uh a good friend brother Uncle of
mine Steve Lobel yes you're the first
artist on Lobel music group yes I am
which is in conjunction with uh Def Jam
so shout out to Steve yeah big deal did
you know who Steve Lobel was like like
how long have you known about Steve how
long have I known about him
what
since a little bit before I met him so
when you met him or did it did you
because you know lobel's a lot yeah like
he hit you no I've known about like hit
you with that aggressive Lobel energy
no I've known about his history like
um and the people he's worked with for
sure so yeah because he told you any
cool Bone Thugs-N-Harmony stories yet
yeah he showed me the picture yeah he's
got a lot of have you been to his house
yet no he's I don't know if he still has
the purple couches you might be able to
tell me he's got these purple couches at
his house they're crazy
um but yeah what what for you like
because you have a huge social media
follow you got over a million followers
how did you amass that following just
through music or were you going viral on
Tick Tock or
um I think it was just from me being
like a kid star and everybody like
followed me because I first went viral
on YouTube for like my first two songs
that I put out seriously okay and
they're over like 70 million views now
um so I feel like that's what people
know me from and then I grew up and
they're like oh where's Brooklyn they
follow me and then I feel like people
just like me because of the stuff I post
damn 70 million views how old were you
when when that happened uh 12. Jesus
yeah shout out to you thank you that
sounds like a gold plaque or something
close right that might be that might be
our like did you put that out through
like this like distribution services
yeah
that sounds like you might you might
need to get a little certification 70
million views a lot yeah